and they throw it away  and  there's the kappa the bow on it was  basically dunking it  oh oh and russ is telling him russ is in  basley's face telling them not to do  that this is not going to sit well again  these two teams will play again next  week at staples center  [Applause]  russ just got tossed  again the youngest team in the nba  [Music]  and  you know those are the quote unwritten  rules if you want to talk about it  whether you believe in them or not  that's up to you  russ  obviously  gave baisley an earful and russ tossed  last three quarters they were absolutely  dominant  just put a bow on it for the thunder it  was right here where russ said  no you're not you're not doing that  and then everybody got in between  and then russ was tossed  you